hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to yandere simulator now in
this video we will be exploring the
brand new way of eliminating a rival
which involves befriending them and if I
know anything about friendship it
involves doing a lot of favors for each
other and then slowly exploiting each
other for personal gain maybe I'm
confusing that with something else but
in this game you get to talk hi senpai
how you doing hey you look good today
you look great you're looking wonderful
anyway so you talk to a certain someone
by the name of boobs McKenzie here and
she obviously has so many problems going
on in her life that she needs other
people to help her out so you go over
here you go
ahh you look today what was which what
defect or defect
hi my uniform doesn't fit yeah I can't
afford one right now
huh I guess there's no point in
complaining it's not like there's
anything you can do Wow is funny you
should ask that because I know all about
the weird size of your boobs I'm very
well aware that your testicle region is
just bizarre misshapen and malformed but
we also have the task to do this because
we can go to the sewing room which is on
the first floor I don't know if this was
a new addition or not but it's on the
first floor right here and you go in
here and you modify the thing right
right right
it should be working okay here we go
okay I had to restart the game because
for some reason I must have my something
up one of the hello I'm you're missing
the seat a little bit there but that's
perfectly okay I'm not gonna question it
too much so supposedly I think we just
modified the uniform because I don't
know how physically I was even capable
of doing that because boobs McKenzie has
quite a few things going wrong with her
but hopefully this will get her on our
good side hi hi boobsie how you doing I
have something for you no way oh this
uniform is tailored to my exact
measurement oh no oh
thank you so much you're welcome your
comfort oh yes hello there your comfort
is my number one priority at all times I
love you you're my Verret oh god I don't
know how much of the sappy [ __ ] I
can take
but boobs McKenzie you're doing great or
whatever I don't know [ __ ] off so now we
go to class and then I believe I believe
okay I believe the next step is on
lunchtime you go up to the rooftop and
then you wait for her to go behind a
certain something and talk to someone
somewhere don't mind me don't mind me at
all you haven't been acting like your
usual self lately is something bothering
you
oh well it's nothing if you don't talk
about it that's fine
but remember I'm your friend and I've
never judged you for anything yeah me
too also that guess there's one thing I
want to talk about I'm listening
ever since my mom died my dad's been
drinking a lot sometimes when he's drunk
he comes into my room and I forget I
said anything I really really don't want
to talk about it yeah what that sounds
really serious what does your tattoo
look I said I don't want to talk about
it just leave me alone okay
geez you have anything to be ashamed of
just tell me what's wrong I'm not gonna
say anything else please just drop it if
you say so but now I'm really worried
okay wow that is some seriously
messed-up [ __ ] but now we got that news
so now what we can do is we can go down
to her locker and then put a note there
to request to meet with her so hands
alright press room button so if we go
over here and then I believe is that
senpai hi what are you doing here oh
it's so good to see you then you go to
her locker and then you're gonna leave a
note requesting I want to speak with you
about domestic abuse please meet me
let's see on the school rooftop at 3:30
I believe I hope you'll be there finish
okay so now what's gonna happen if I'm
not late for class she's gonna go up to
the roof after she sees her note and
then she's gonna go up there 3:30 might
have been a little bit too soon
but we shall see if this pays off which
hopefully it shall I had to do this
again I'm it's now Tuesday and she's
gonna come in and I'm gonna tell her to
meet her at 7:30 because when she comes
in she should see the note pretty soon
after she arrives and then she should be
able to just go right up huh yeah like
that
maybe I should meet them maybe you
should so go for it go now go now that
now would be good not now lady lady lady
oh she's leaving okay does this means
she's going on the roof
might be okay we're gonna follow you
we're gonna understand what you're doing
but we're going to try to comprehend
your actions she's gonna go over there
yes yes yes this is exactly what we were
hoping for so she's gonna go over there
is she gonna do our thing and she's
gonna go over there she's gonna do our
thing and then she is going to be right
there then I need to try not to push her
off the roof but over here I can offer
help oh look you're the one who wanted
to meet me here yes please stop
intersecting your arm with your boobage
that you wanted to talk about domestic
abuse you yes I heard you talking with
sake I want to help you with your
problem uh-huh what is your father doing
to you yeah oh you've got it all wrong
my father doesn't do anything to me okay
then what does he do when he gets drunk
he
hee hee cries OH what he cries and talks
about his debt problems ha your father
is in debt when my mom died last year my
family lost a lot of money my dad took
out a loan so that he could continue to
pay for my tuition fees but it turns out
that he borrowed money from some really
shady people they raised the interest
rate by 10% every ten days and they
threatened to get violent with him if he
doesn't pay up loan sharks no sure
trying to help my dad get out of debt
I'm trying to earn money any way I can
but the only ways to make money fast or
gross mm-hmm
what's the name of the business that
your father borrowed money from um I
think it's called dontcha coulombs Ron
Shawn going to get your father out of
there Ron shock Lords no please don't
get involved I don't there's anything
you could do about dad be so quick to
judge you'd be surprised
ha ha ha ha I know many are tricks but I
don't think there's anything else to say
thanks for letting me talk about my
problems welcome Busey don't worry about
a thing because I know exactly what to
do it's almost like I've got a special
intuition about these things matters of
the mind you see and I will get to the
bottom of the matter in no
time so there is a new character in
school which I now just connected the
dots and I'm pretty sure I know exactly
who she is this lady right here if you
just quick hello send it off that is
Masumi roan Shaku
so masoom a roan Shaku needs to be
kidnapped and we know how to kidnap
don't we so I need to go to school hang
on one second need to go to the nurse's
office for stuff and things nothing you
need to be too concerned about but it's
probably something that's not gonna go
too well for you well let me just do
this where do you go
you still following me good you better
hurry the [ __ ] up right so we're in here
bada bing bada boom biology increase
follower valid syringe held or closed
all right we're gonna close this door
lose it you're gonna come over here all
right boink okay all good in this
neighborhood boink
time to go to class learn more biology
wait out I'm a bookworm it's a vulgar to
me education is fornication I love
spending my time in class thinking about
the people that I'm gonna kidnap already
diseases yeah all right so now this
night we go down to the basement and
then we talk to this person hi we're
gonna record a little video I don't know
why
huh I don't know why this was only
available at night but ok watch this
video
uh-huh no okay
uh-huh you scumbag what have you done my
daughter these are interesting vocalized
texts we haven't harmed her yet
ever want to see her again you must do
as I say what do you want for me uh all
of your clients from debt all are you
insane
that would sink my business for every
day that your clients remain in debt
I'll remove one of your daughter's
fingers if you want her back in one
piece
you must act immediately there you
monster
me monster I know me a monster me okay
good decision thank you my dad just got
a phone call he says his debts have been
wiped clean convenient about that you do
this oh you know yeah what did you do
you don't want to know tell you Oh for
legal reasons kind of scary but I can't
remember the last time I saw my dad this
happy I don't know what you did and I'm
afraid to ask you should be but you
saved my dad thank you so much um you're
welcome
yeah see we're in tune or one in the one
can't express how grateful I am
if there's anything you need me to do
for you just say the word okay there is
one thing I'd like to ask you for Oh
please meet me at my
else tomorrow oh [ __ ] before school
begins oh I have something important to
tell you I thought I was gonna ask her
to stay away from sin by but I guess
we're gonna get her thank you
this is a long roundabout way to deal
with someone but I guess it gets him
away from school an Arri Chan waits
until the clock strikes midnight she
renders Masumi to oh wait what that did
huh oh oh that was me returning her oh
okay I got it
hello welcome to my humble abode I live
here all alone because I probably killed
living son young John where are your
parents
overseas uh-huh so you take care of
yourself I was born my universe I manage
well I want to thank you again for
helping my dad uh-huh I won't ask what
you did I'm sure it's something that you
wouldn't want to talk about well I can
probably tell you now considering what's
about to happen
loan sharks are awful people uh-huh I
agree just like me stupid chains well I
was trying to make money but my biggest
regret was getting Saki involved yeah I
never told her about my dad's dead but I
did tell her that I needed money oh my
god it's not funny
stop let me go Oh oh my god I mean I
knew it was gonna happen but holy [ __ ]
oh man that was terrifying that was
horrifying
holy crap whoa whoa
Oh anyway that is the newest way to
eliminate your rival in yonder region
Wow
ow something holy [ __ ]
anyway so thank you everybody so much
for watching there's gonna be new
updates to this game all the time but if
you want to see something else for me in
this series let me know in the comments
below thank you again everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye oh god boy
what big feet you have the Badgers will
do that with